Andreas von dieser Gruppe wir haben es
eben gerade gehört das sind nicht sehr
viele aber dennoch also fast 100
Menschen wer kann wird da jetzt
überhaupt rausgehen und wenn ja wie was
hast du da für Informationen heute aus
Berlin also die Reisewarnung die das
Auswärtige Amt ausgesprochen hat gilt
für alle deutschen Staatsbürger minus
muss man sagen minus die deutschen
Diplomaten und Minus die Soldaten die
noch sind in
Niger wie viele Deutsche davon Gebrauch
machen werden ist die Frage weil man
natürlich auch hier in Berlin davon
ausgeht dass deutsche Staatsbürger die
im Niger leben dass die schon ich sag
mal ziemlich hart sind im Nehmen und wir
haben es ja auch gerade von Herrn Robak
Wert im gehört dass er und seine
Mitarbeiter dort bleiben wollen also es
wird eine relativ kleine Zahl sein davon
geht man aus in Berlin die die
Aufforderung die der Aufforderung
nachkommen nieder zu verlassen und
deswegen verzichtet eben auch
Deutschland zum Beispiel auf eine eigene
Evakuierung Mission deswegen sagt das
auswärtige leute bitte nehmt das Angebot
der Franzosen an die ja gesagt haben wir
nehmen deutsche und andere EU-Bürger mit
auf unsere Flüge und da geht man im
Moment davon aus in Berlin dass das
reicht dass das keine deutsche Mission
nötig sein wird die deutschen Diplomaten
und die es gibt die deutsche Botschaft
ist anders als die französische
Botschaft bisher nicht Ziel geworden von
Ausschreitungen sie ist aber
vorsichtshalber verlegt worden an einen
sicheren Ort in der Hauptstadt an den
Flughafen dort wo auch die deutschen
Soldaten sind und da gibt es im Moment
keine Pläne zu evakuieren da ist im
Moment der Stand wir halten unser
Personal dort für Sicherheit die
deutsche Botschaft bleibt also offen
auch wenn sie verlegt wurde aber
trotzdem es steht ein deutscher Flieger
am Flughafen in die Armee der steht da
bereit warum ist der denn oder wofür ist
der dann vorgesehen warum ist der dort
das ist der Notausgang
man beobachtet die Lage hier sehr genau
in Berlin und man muss natürlich auch
einräumen dass man von diesem Putsch und
von dieser ganzen Entwicklung in die
total überrascht war und deswegen das
soll nicht noch mal passieren deswegen
steht dieser Flieger da der hat seine
400m und der hat genau die Kapazität
alle deutschen Soldaten alle deutschen
Diplomaten und vielleicht auch noch ein
paar übrig gebliebene deutsche die dann
noch ausreisen wollen mitzunehmen
deswegen steht ja da für den schlimmsten
Fall von dem keiner hofft dass er
passiert aber man will vorbereitet sein
und nicht noch einmal im von so
einer Entwicklung überrascht werden was
auch schon die Bundeswehrsoldaten
angesprochen die sind also auch dort vor
Ort in Niger bleiben also auch zunächst
vor Ort die koordinieren nämlich den
Abzug der Soldaten aus Mali also dem
Nachbarland wir haben es vorhin auf
einer Karte ja gesehen ist das jetzt
davon beeinträchtigt dieser Abzug aus
Mali was bedeutet das jetzt für diese
Aktion
also dieser
lufttransportstützpunkt der ist
unglaublich wichtig nicht nur für den
Abzug aus Mali aber auch
die Deutschen haben ja gesagt sie ziehen
aus Mali ab und in Mali steht jede Menge
Gerät teures Gerät Gerät das auch
Geheimnis das nicht in falsche Hände
fallen soll und jeder Tag an dem es
jetzt nicht ausgeflogen werden kann der
kann nicht aufgeholt werden also
deswegen es müssen bereits jetzt in Mali
militärische Sachen zerstört werden
gesprengt werden damit sie nicht nach
dem Abzug in falsche Hände fallen das
sind Bilder die so ein bisschen auch an
die Situation in Afghanistan erinnern
obwohl das natürlich insgesamt politisch
nicht vergleichbar ist aber das wollte
man eigentlich nicht noch mal und man
hat gesagt alles gut alles kein Problem
wir gehen ja über unseren Lufttransport
Stützpunkt in Niger raus wir schaffen
das auch in der Zeit das ist jetzt schon
nicht mehr zu halten und deswegen ist
die Bundesregierung haben gerade im
Gespräch mit anderen Ländern mit
Nachbarländern des uniga und versucht
ganz schnell Verträge zu schließen dass
man das Material aus Mali über diese
Länder zum Beispiel über Algerien
rausschafft aber das dauert Zeit das
dauert Diplomatie und das ist alles ja
sehr schwierig und das ist eigentlich
für Deutschland das eigentliche Drama an
dieser Situation gerade und Deutschland
hat ja auch geholfen nikrische
Spezialkräfte auszubilden hatte also
auch natürlich Zeit und auch viel Geld
Jahre lang investiert ist das jetzt
alles umsonst wie geht das weiter es
liegt das alles jetzt brach ja das liegt
Prag das ist eine riesengroße
Katastrophe im Prinzip ist die ganze
Sahel Strategie der Bundesregierung seit
letzter Woche in trömann von allen
Staaten der sah halt so ne du hast es ja
auch schon öfter gesagt war Niger der
einzige das einzige Land das doch so ein
bisschen Hoffnung verbreitet hatte dem
es demokratische Wahlen gab in dem es
eine demokratische Regierung gab und im
Prinzip ist in den vergangenen Jahren
jeder Deutsche Außenpolitiker immer
wieder nach niedergefahren in den
niedergefahren Kanzlerin Merkel die
ganzen Verteidigungsminister Kanzler
Scholz war gerade erst da weil es eben
so ein hoffnungsstart war und
Deutschland hat nicht nur Jahre
investiert und viel Hoffnung investiert
das hat auch sehr viel Geld investiert
und
selbst wenn sage ich mal der Präsident
bei so nun doch wieder eingesetzt werden
sollte durch politischen Druck
vielleicht auch durch eine militärische
Intervention ist natürlich die Frage
hier die man sich hier in Berlin stellt
wie viel Autorität hätte der dann
überhaupt also das ist wieder so wird
wie vorher glaubt in Berlin niemand und
das ist wirklich eine sehr sehr
schlechte Nachricht für die ganze Region
und auch für Deutschland